dans les studios de warner brothers
games à montréal les employés test les
derniers jeux développés par
l'entreprise pour le chef du studio pas
de doute
montréal est devenue une plaque
tournante dans la création de jeux vidéo
on se rend pas compte à quel point c'est
un nouveau fleuron économique que peu de
secteurs où on est premier au monde en
jeu vidéo on peut affirmer qu'on est
parmi les meilleurs au monde et ça ça
vaut son pesant d'or
l'industrie du jeu à montréal c'est les
mégaproductions assassin's creed
d'ubisoft ou encore batman qui a été
réalisée ici dans les studios de warner
les jeux qui sont fait à montréal et au
québec sont parmi les meilleurs au monde
s'est fait signer blockbusters comme au
niveau du ferry-boat boston de cinéma
les mégaproductions à plusieurs dizaines
de millions parti de rien à la fin des
années 90 l'industrie du jeu vidéo à
montréal embauche aujourd'hui environ
6000 personnes au canada
plus du tiers des emplois dans le
secteur sont maintenant concentrés dans
le centre-ville de la métropole
québécoise
montréal c'est un endroit où il ya la
plus haute concentration la proue
prorata en fait 6000 personnes dans un
rayon ici de 1,02 qui la main martin
carrier convaincu l'industrie a le
potentiel de grès des milliers d'emplois
additionnels le plus la présence de
grands studios a permis l'émergence de
joueurs indépendant montréal prend de
plus en plus de place dans la création
de jeux sur mobile ou de jeux sociaux
ça a beaucoup évolué et enfin depuis ce
qu'on peut penser et un an les 187
l'arrivée d'ubisoft
bref montréal peut se vanter d'être chef
de file du jeu vidéo au cinéma la
métropole s'impose de plus en plus dans
le domaine des effets visuels
il ya beaucoup de productions étrangères
mais grosse production
l'année dernière on a référencé environ
40 points 45 productions étrangères qui
en donnait du contrat des entreprises
effets visuels installés au québec que
ce soit les effets visuels de x-men en
passant par robocop ou encore game of
thrones
la valeur des contrats attribués au
studio montréalais est passé de 96
millions à 139 millions de dollars en
l'espace d'une année selon le bureau du
cinéma et de la télévision
ce secteur connaît depuis six ans une
croissance annuelle moyenne de 26%
les studios embauche environ 1500
personnes
et comme dans le jeu il s'agit pour la
plupart des hommes de moins de 30 ans
qui gagne en moyenne 65 mille dollars
par année
on dit que l'industrie apprécié le
talent créatif des montréalais mais
autant dans le jeu que dans les effets
spéciaux
ce qui attire les studios c'est bien
entendu les généreux crédits d'impôt le
québec est très compétitif en terme d'
avantages fiscaux qu'il faut offrir à
ses productions étrangères
un producteur qui vient faire des effets
visuels au québec peut avoir jusqu'à 1
38% ont créé l'impôt donc sur un contre
admettons d' d'un million de dollars et
peut recevoir jusqu'à 380 mille dollars
en incitatif fiscal le gouvernement du
québec a flirté avec l'idée de réduire
les crédits d'impôt accordés à
l'industrie mais s'est finalement ravisé
je pense que de façon indéniable avec le
temps plusieurs raisons ce qui était
investi dans jeux vidéo ont rapporté
beaucoup plus que le montant initial
martin carrier insiste l'arrivée des
studios à donner un nouveau souffle à
certains secteurs du centre-ville
on pense à ubisoft s'est installée
c'était un peu des articles nous aussi
chez où on est on est dans le quartier
des spectacles près de la place émilie
gamelin son quartier qui est en pleine
émergence
c'est aussi ce que ça apporte en termes
économiques
warner brothers games occupe aujourd'hui
plusieurs étages de la place dupuis un
édifice longtemps boudée par
l'entreprise privée ici vincent
maisonneuve radio canada montréal